on one of the first pages of stephen
hawking's phd thesis there is a
handwritten note saying no copying
without the author's consent
but just before he passed away stephen
hawking actually allowed for his phd
thesis which was titled properties of
expanding universes to be released
publicly online
that decision crashed the university of
cambridge website because so many people
wanted to take a look at it
so today i thought i would try and see
what all the fuss is about this 120 page
document was written in 1965
when hawking was 23 years old and it
represents all of the work he did as a
graduate student at cambridge he was
officially awarded the phd in 1966 when
he was 24
and this was before he was famous and
even before he was in a wheelchair
in fact hawking was able to hand write
on the acknowledgements page
this dissertation is my original work
s.w hawking
it had been a couple of years earlier
when he was 21 that he was diagnosed
with motor neuron disease finishing this
thesis was something that after the
diagnosis looked like it might not
happen at all
hawking was initially given only two
years to live and he became
understandably quite depressed he spent
very little time on his research and a
lot of time in his room apparently
listening to classical music reading
science fiction and drinking hawking's
family and his supervisor dennis syama
encouraged him to return to his research
and after a while when his condition
stabilized and hawking realized that
death wasn't imminent he did return to
finish his thesis hawking is quite well
known for some of his work in science
communication including his book a brief
history of time that book was written
for a general audience but is still
jokingly referred to as the most unread
book of all time now this thesis was not
written for a general audience but
instead for experts in cosmology so it
is not easy to understand and there are
a lot of calculations but i'll do my
best to share the main ideas with you
i myself am not an expert in this topic
so it's just what i've been able to pick
up
i would like to quickly thank galaxy
lamps for sponsoring this video the
amazing background that you see today is
from their galaxy projector 2.0 which is
something that you can easily point at
the walls or ceiling to turn any room
into a kind of planetarium it is really
quite mesmerizing and i'd love to keep
using it as a backdrop for future videos
it integrates with an app to change
color options speed and to set a timer
but you can also just use the six
inbuilt modes if you don't want to use
your phone
you can also set it up with amazon alexa
or google assistant it has a three stand
system which is really easy to set up or
rotate and it doesn't make any noise it
has a laser feature which makes the
stars or you can just have the nebula
lights if you would like to get one for
yourself or maybe as a gift perhaps for
christmas then you can head to galaxy
lamps dot co slash tibbies and get a 15
discount that link will only work for
100 people and you can find it down in
the description as well
so looking at the thesis it is all about
the expansion of the universe and the
first line of the introduction is that
the idea that the universe is expanding
is of recent origin
he talks about how all of the early
cosmologies were essentially stationary
including einsteins
but he says there are grave difficulties
associated with this including the fact
that if the stars had been radiating
energy at their present rates for an
infinite time they would need an
infinite supply of energy
and there's a mention of the fact that
not long before this thesis was written
that the discovery of the recession of
the nebulae by hubble had led to the
abandonment of static models in favor of
ones which were expanding
so this expansion is a relatively new
idea and hawking goes on to say there
are a few possibilities
one is that the universe may have
expanded from a highly dense state a
finite time ago which is the big bang
model or there's the bouncing or
oscillating model where the universe is
going through periods of expansion and
contraction finally hawking says it is
possible that the expansion may have
been proceeding at much the same rate
for an infinite time for this it would
be necessary to postulate some form of
continual creation of matter in order to
prevent the expansion from reducing the
density to zero
this is what is called the steady state
model now hawking will go on to talk a
lot more about that it's also important
to establish that a lot of this thesis
relates to einstein's general theory of
relativity the idea that space and time
are related in this kind of fabric
called space-time where massive objects
can warp space-time explaining things
like planetary orbits or a gravitational
pull einstein himself had been so sure
that the universe was static and not
expanding that he had added the
cosmological constant to his equations
in order to keep it that way which he
would famously go on to call his
greatest blunder
chapter one is about the hoyl nalika
theory of gravitation and basically why
it is wrong
fred hoyle was an astronomer at
cambridge and is most famous for his
theory of stellar nucleosynthesis
showing that elements up to iron can be
formed inside stars in nuclear reactions
he also came up with the term big bang
which he used to mock the theory because
he rejected it he was instead a
proponent of the steady state model of
the universe that the universe didn't
come from anything but is infinitely old
and the same in all directions and at
all times in the past and future
a steady state universe doesn't evolve
over time jayant nalika was fred hoyle's
phd student and is still working in
astronomy he's currently based in india
together they came up with this theory
to explain how the universe could be
expanding and still in a steady state as
hawking said in his introduction this
would require some continual creation of
mata so we have here the big bang model
if all of these dots represent galaxies
then with the expansion of the universe
the distance between everything and
between all the galaxies increases then
for the steady-state model the distance
between individual galaxies marked here
does increase by the same amount when
the universe expands but this time there
is extra matter created in between
so the average distance between galaxies
remains the same
hoyl and nalika call this new mata the c
field and interestingly it is based off
work from richard feynman's thesis
feynman had this theory of fields that
were half backwards and half forwards
which was derived from an action
principle that involved interactions
between pairs of particles in feynman's
thesis he was able to show that these
fields could combine to give an observed
field
and hoyl and nalikar used the same
theory for space time you can even see
that they start their theory here by
deriving it from something they call the
action
an integration over the world lines of
particles
funnily enough when hawking came to
cambridge as a student he had actually
wanted hoyle as his own supervisor
and he was a bit upset when he was
placed with sayama but then in this
thesis he's really going after hoyle's
theory so maybe it worked out for the
best
all of this math goes on to show that
the steady state theory doesn't match
observation
he says that it excludes models that
seem to correspond to the actual
universe hawking points out lots of
problems with the theory but
interestingly one of them is that it
would require some particles to have the
property of negative gravitational mass
and he says there does not seem to be
any matter having these properties in
our region of space
and that the introduction of negative
masses would probably raise more
difficulties than it would solve and
this was actually before we had the idea
of dark energy which kind of does have
anti-gravitational or negative mass
properties chapter 2 is about
perturbations these small variations in
space-time
to describe this hawking uses the metric
tensor
and works with the einstein field
equations i've got a link down in the
description to some videos that cover
this math of general relativity in a
much better way that i can here
but all this math is done to show the
conclusion that galaxies cannot form as
the result of the growth of small
perturbations but maybe this is where
hawking got it wrong because these days
we actually believe that that is exactly
how galaxies form however now we have
the additional component of dark matter
providing enough invisible mass to hold
the galaxies together but it wasn't
until 1980 that we had the idea of dark
matter when vera rubin published her
work on galaxy masses and it was around
that same year that dark energy was also
proposed but this thesis was written 15
years earlier
but i suppose statements like this one
from hawking do add to the weight of
reason as to why we needed something
like dark matter because without it
there are a few things that just don't
add up
you can see how differently a thesis was
written without modern tools like latex
and word processes to type out the
equations
in fact hawking's thesis was typed up by
his wife jane while she was also
completing her own graduate studies
no thesis would be complete without some
spelling mistakes that went unnoticed
but i only noticed them now because of a
lack of ability to understand what's
going on with the rest of the page
chapter 3 is gravitational radiation in
an expanding universe
this actually relates to what we now
call gravitational waves they were first
predicted by einstein in 1915 and we
observed them for the first time in
2015.
ligo picked up a signal from a merger of
two black holes that sent gravitational
ripples all the way to earth
hawking mentions them a bit in chapter
two but calls them slightly academic
since gravitational radiation has not
yet been detected let alone investigated
and the treatment in chapter 3 is much
more mathematical if you can believe it
we've got the field equations tenses
metrics this is the math of general
relativity it's about describing how
space moves and if anything it's really
all about geometry
not much of this thesis is hawking just
pondering about ideas for the universe
you can see that really most of it is
about proving those ideas with
mathematics
it's why topics like cosmology and
general relativity are almost less of a
physics discipline and more about
learning the math
often these researchers work within math
departments
of course everything looks strange when
i'm just throwing it in front of you on
a page and it would make a bit more
sense if you're following it through
line by line
like even with just more basic algebra
if someone just showed you a random page
of their working it'd be hard to make
sense of it this math is hard because
not a lot of us are very fluent with
tenses in this kind of way
but that doesn't mean it's impossible to
learn
now i'm glad you're still around because
chapter four is the last chapter and
it's probably the most important it's
about singularities
he talks about open and closed models
for the universe
in an open universe space has negative
curvature and the universe has no bounds
and will expand forever
for a closed universe space has positive
curvature
and is more like the surface of a sphere
there's one other option which is if
space has no curvature at all which is a
flat universe
the evidence we have now makes us
believe that we live in a flat universe
and hawking investigates this using a
mathematical tool called a calci surface
hawking says that a calci surface will
be taken to mean a complete connected
space-like surface that intersects every
time-like and null line once and once
only so i think it's some kind of slice
through space time and it represents an
instant in time
for a closed universe with positive
curvature the calcium surface is said to
be compact whereas the non-compact
surface represents an open universe or
one with negative curvature
at this time the mathematician roger
penrose had a theory of a space-time
singularity in the centre of black holes
and hawking in his thesis is applying
this idea to not just black holes but
the entire universe
his bold claims about singularities
include saying that penrose's methods
are applicable to
non-compact calci surfaces
that is universes which have negative or
zero curvature
that is open or flat
it means hawking is really proving that
singularities can exist and are in fact
essential for our universe
that there is some infinitely small and
dense point at the beginning of
space-time and he's not just saying it
he can actually prove it and here's his
proof right here
in fact it is a proof by contradiction
he starts with saying
assume space-time is singularity-free
doing this he encounters contradictions
his contradictions are that the universe
would be both open and closed at the
same time he says this is a
contradiction thus the assumption that
space-time is non-singular must be false
later hawking would go on to work quite
closely with roger penrose and extend
these theories of singularities they
published a 1970 proof that the universe
must have begun as a singularity if it
is to obey the general theory of
relativity
it was these mathematical proofs of
singularities and of the big bang that
hawking first became quite well known
for
he then moved on to working with black
holes and showed that they can emit what
is now called hawking radiation
and later he became involved with
quantum mechanics and thinking about
ways to unite it with general relativity
when hawking released his thesis to the
public he said that by making my phd
thesis open access
i hope that i inspire people to look up
at the stars and not down at their feet
to wonder about our place in the
universe and to try to make sense of the
cosmos
when he later heard that so many people
had tried to download it he said that he
hoped they were not disappointed by it
i also hope that you gained some value
in what i was able to share with you
thanks for watching thanks also to my
patreon supporters including today's
patreon cat of the day halloween
[Music]
you